So what does Tim Ferriss do at two in the morning besides drink Portuguese,
white wine and watch the Bourne identity for the 157th time.
He does pen tricks,
which is what he does all the time as his own fidget.
So nef is talking in third person.
Let's check out some Hendrix.
So we're going to do these roughly in order of difficulty,
but it may be slightly out of order.
All right,
so this is called the helicopter.
Pretty obvious.
I'm just going to give you a little showcase of of things that come first so you
can get a pretty good idea of what's possible just by looking at that.
So helicopter is so named because of the emotion and just like that.
And I recommend you use a big,
because it's,
it's relatively well balanced and a the right diameter.
Okay.
So what we're doing here is pushing us down so that the thumb,
that middle finger is at the very center of the pen in the back and the thumb is
about one thumb width away from the center on top,
right?
The top of the thumb,
meaning the part that's parallel to the ground there is going to be parallel to
the ground.
And uh,
here I'm pushing the pen into both my index and middle finger and then I'm
essentially snapping these two and spins across the back of my thumb,
like so.
And you can do that all day long.
And uh,
that's probably the most common that you'll see in Japan and Taiwan and the
really good kids.
We'll do it one way and then knock it back the other way.
I can't do that.
All right,
so the drummer so named,
because you'll see guys like Tommy Lee do that.
All right.
Now if you look at it from that angle,
it looks like it's going up and down and it looks very cool.
If you look at it from the front,
it's actually just that,
that emotion.
So really what I'm doing is
moving the top two fingers back and forth as this spins right in front of the
first knuckle.
Like so.
And the way you,
that's been started as I'm pulling down with my index finger.
So the middle finger is basically a brace pushing down at the top finger and
then I'm catching the back of the pen and this little web and then as soon as I
pull this back,
it gets that initial spin and then you keep it going with these two fingers,
it looks pretty cool.
All right.
Then we have,
uh,
I suppose what I would call the,
the pincher.
And the reason I'm going to call that none of these things have names as far as
I know,
it looks like that.
And the reason I call it the pincher,
it's very hard to see what this motion is.
This is actually the first one I learned,
but one of the hardest is the same motion that I'm using to get that Tommy Lee
spin started.
But it's in between my middle of my ring finger and as it con,
as it flips through,
I'm going to catch it in between my index and my ring finger.
So it looks like that and then it swings behind and I catch it back in this
position.
So it looks like this
like that very slowly.
Okay.
That's what it looks like faster.
That makes sense.
Okay.
And you can either push down here or you can do it on the thumb itself and
that's what it looks like.
And when you get better at it,
you can do it from different positions.
You can start here for example
like that and then go up more.
Or you can even,
it's a little hard to do looking through the camera.
So I just jumped.
I just skipped these two fingers and went from here to here.
All right,
so you can get tricky with it.
All right.
The the wheel was what I'll call this one here with one of the,
one of the easier ones again,
and then you can mix it all together.
Uh,
really all you're doing is I'm pushing off of the,
the thumb here between these two fingers and it's pulling,
it's doing a straight circle through like that and you end up in this somewhat
awkward position.
Then you can segway into a different mood.
So it looks like that,
we'll just call that the wheel.
That's probably the easiest.
And you'll see that I'm just pushing it down.
And then this very familiar pushing with the middle finger,
pretty similar to how we started the last move.
Instead of going in a circle like that,
we're going in a,
we're pushing down on the top of the thumb so it's further extended on the
fingertips coming straight back like a wheel.
All right.
And then the last one that we'll have is what I'll call the flip and pretty self
explanatory.
It looks like that though.
Now that sound you just heard,
you will hear thousands and thousands of times.
Oh,
all right,
well so much for ending with a flourish,
but it uh,
it looks like that and the better you get,
you can actually keep your hand flat on a table and flip it and catch it without
moving your hand at all like that.
Right?
So that'd be a flip in the way you do that.
Again,
the same motion,
but you're going to be flicking out with your,
with your ring finger to get the extension.
So it goes away from your hand.
It's going to rotate falling and it's going to land right here in the riding
position
like that.
Right?
And then you put it all together.
You can do all sorts of fancy stuff.
So I could do a wheel to the penser
helicopter,
to the Tommy Lee and so forth and so on.
You just,
we'll get to the point where you'll do this while reading a newspaper and it'll
drive everybody.
Absolutely.
Apeshit so have fun.
If you don't have OCD already,
this will give it to you.
Signing off.